i didn't realize you said this one to me
there's a couple who are sent to me
i didn't realize what uh
what a gem our friend thomas murphy was
gonna be
so thomas thomas murphy's got some big
plans can i say something here thomas
murphy is a guy
who he doesn't just fly by the seat of
his pants he doesn't [ __ ] he's not a
spontaneous chaotic guy
he likes to make plans royce he likes to
make his plans
mm-hmm and he likes to have them set
in stone ready to go and he doesn't like
to deviate from his plans
yeah okay now i get i look mike i know i
know some people that you know plan
stuff like a year in advance i think
those people are crazy that's a lot to
plan
uh let's see what thomas's plans are hi
it's me thomas out of china again yes
in the year 2027 which i'll be 43 years
old on july 29th
on a day i want to take my cousin
vincent
kaylee if she has a swimsuit bikini on
sierra yes her husband me and my mom
to water park in in the future yes
so eight years from now eight years
eight years from now he wants to take
his uh but it's sometimes you want to
get because like the thing is right
it's just like with flying and stuff
like that if you wait till the [ __ ]
week before and you book it it's
expensive
i would imagine that booking i would
imagine paying for your
for your water park passes it's free it
should be free at that point
yeah it's so far ahead because i want to
show vincent
a good time at the water park why not
show vincent
a good time at the water park now like
right now take him now
also there's water parks in california
take him to a local water park
he's 10 years old now he's 10
when he's ten so is his baby three okay
that makes sense okay
yeah that makes sense the plan probably
don't want a grown
man bringing a uh baby to a water park
oh that's a recipe for disaster right
thomas yep so uh here i am i hugged i
hugged him too hard
and he died so i uh i put him in his own
tube
in the lazy river and uh and he died
apparently you're not supposed to put a
three-year-old
uh nor own lazy river but i had to get
out of the lacey river because they were
playing taylor swift and i had to drink
i had to leave i had to leave the wave
pool because they were playing taylor
swift so i left a three-year-old in the
wave pool
and then the baby was flung from the
wave pool
ah [ __ ] and also it will be on my
birthday july 29th
yes it will be because uh yeah
vincent's never been to a water park in
his life
and all three is darth vader in the room
with him what's that noise
no it's bane tell them about the water
park thomas
uh yeah could you imagine just
bane in a tank top in a swimsuit but he
still has the mask on
flip-flops with flip-flops yes
and instead of his vest he has a life
for a life vest on perfect
the laser river is a little too slow
paced for me
i like a good water slide that's a nice
inner tube what would happen if i
removed it
[Laughter]
it needs the tube because the mask is
made of metal and it would make him sink
yeah he stopped at me so he flips every
time he goes
straight under
in florida i saw brandon at the turnpike
tolls
and he's like my cousin like i told me
is my cousin yes brandon
i don't i don't understand is he a
cricket breeder
is that his job i work breeding crickets
he's a professional cricket you can race
them a lot of people don't know you can
race
qrikets mm-hmm all right so some
one of our fans and i'm somebody
somebody pointed out in the back of the
bus chat that said mercer was right the
other day
because i said on night wave if i hired
this guy to just do like all the charts
and stuff
for my crypto i'd be a billionaire oh
yeah cause he's so uh
like he knows nothing about
cryptocurrency but if you just taught
him the basics and showed him how to
chart
he would be going um so on july 27
2023 uh bitcoin will be
23 248 and 38 cents and you'll be like
there's no way and then
like you'll forget about the
conversation and then one day you'll see
it on the news you'll be like son of a
[ __ ]
he was right down to the dollar
uh see a real quick stream cgi seagull
says for six dollars
is mega mills a new jim norton project
no because this is actually still on
youtube
uh so this somebody one of our fans and
i'm sorry i wish i gave him credit but
send this to us his obsession with
taylor swift
is not only weird but i'm gonna show you
some stuff and tell me it's not getting
a little dangerous
all right oh is this are we getting a
bjork type situation
i don't think so yet but we'll see hi
it's me thomas and just let you know
there's a warning
there is gonna be a lot of swearing in
this video there's gonna be a lot of
swearing in this video
no you can't say he didn't warn people
so good for him all right there you go
you heard hey you heard that d live he
warned everybody that trip
you're gonna give [ __ ] thomas here a
show so he can taylor swift live on your
platform
that would be big news that'd be big
[ __ ] that'll be pewdiepie you want a
lot of eyes on your platform trip
i'm telling you listen to me and make me
me a marketing guy what could have
a pop star alive on the air i don't
think we can do that yeah you're right
we probably couldn't get taylor swift
what about like uh kelly clarkson
carly ray jepson yeah we could get her
maybe
demi lovato oh [ __ ]
or you could just get kesha because for
the most part she doesn't resist how
about this trip we bring demi lovato on
the platform and we give her a hot
we don't tell her it's hot and then she
takes it
she shoots it up but it's really drano
what did she notice the color it tripped
why can't we be partners
i don't get it we're having fun we're
having a good time
we act like we're bad for this like
we're bad look for this platform
the best part is just how [ __ ]
indignant we are about it
how dare you trip and we're like nah
we're actually our pretty [ __ ] guys
pretty terrible
it's okay
[Laughter]
all right look is this important sorry
girl december 13th is taylor swift's
birthday
i [ __ ] hate her [ __ ] you you piece of
[ __ ]
yes i don't like tara swish she's a
horrible singer
i don't like her december 13th is her
birthday
yeah keep your dick beaters off
taylor swift's dick beaters somebody's
dick beaters
look how he spelled it you know you're
and he's probably right too taylor swift
probably is a hand stuff girl she's
probably really
bad hand jobs yeah she want to get a bad
hand job come on
suck it a little bit and she's just
awesome no i just flipped my lipstick
yeah my lip liner is perfect
you [ __ ] [ __ ] of my stuff
because i got the word my head dick
beaters you just learned that word by
the way
and also yeah [ __ ] you you son of a
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you tara swift
what did she do well okay the fans
haven't
you think we're obsessed our our fans
have
been detectives well they figured it out
we watched these videos we've got them
on the case
i've watched some we've all watched
these videos
he really likes katy perry though
specifically the song california girls
you're to
find out he did mention that yeah taylor
swift and katy perry for a while were
feuding
like they up there i was told like there
was some fewer they were throwing shade
at each other really two women didn't
get along
right same field stop talking bad about
women mike so weird
so uh they didn't get along and they're
thinking that's why he hates taylor
swift because he loves katy perry
and also uh oh yeah just let you know
all of you do not buy tara swiss music
she's a horrible singer
i also told star 113 to stop playing it
he calls them he calls the radio
stations and tells us
they must love him and you know what
sucks like
nowadays they won't do it because
they'll all get fired but like when i
was working in radio 10 years ago crazy
people would call the station you aired
this
of course complain to them
they better listen to my demands or else
what or else what and also uh oh yeah
friday is a new star wars movie i will
see that
no no [ __ ]
and sierra if you're hearing this do not
buy tarot swiss music sierra
she's a horrible singer do not buy her
music
i'm not a fan of her music at all but
what if what if
what if somebody is and they want to
cancel the uber ride
that's dude that's so funny yeah it is
it is
you know and i think now we're figuring
out why he goes to these anger classes
and also uh what else i'm gonna say oh
yeah
the next video is give me the card that
i'm gonna read on youtube
yes and i hope you like my video too see
okay so
now uh as we go
he got in trouble at work into the mind
of me he seems to get in trouble at work
a lot
but this time was a really well let's
play it it has to do with katy perry
hi it's me thomas and today is day that
uh i told
i mean i told bria this my employee used
to work here
i wish i could give you a hug if you
wear a string
swimsuit bikini co-worker at safeway
you can't say that to a co-worker well
uh
you're not thomas murphy you you can't
do that
you you can't that's gotta make so many
girls uncomfortable
i can't wait well look what is watch his
reasoning i wish i could give you a hug
if you wear a string swimsuit bikini
because i heard a song katy perry's
california girls but she went to
management on me
she did yes
and also oh yeah and then on the 13th i
got called to the office
because it was harassment it's because
of the song
i should have told him it was because of
his song california girls by katie
oh i'm sure you did tell them i'm sure
you did he just i guarantee you the
whole
actually it's a song by katy perry and
they were just like
look man can you just not do it like i
don't have to fire a [ __ ] person
i don't even have my conscience i don't
want to be that guy and they're putting
me in a weird like now i'm between the
company and the [ __ ]
he's already lost one job too remember
he said that before i don't know why but
he has
i'm making my video somebody walked into
the kitchen i'm just doing a video on
youtube
oh god and there's somebody walking out
watching him this is the song
and i'm off on thursday today i mean i
mean i'll be on thursday yes you hear
them in the background i will
you watch i'm waiting to hear like a
break room microwave
[Music]
beep beep beep
also uh it's gonna rain today it will
so do you stop everything else i want to
say
sorry it's just because of distraction
right here i guess i better go
so comment down below and let me think
about this
so i guess i'll be going so bye
i i would i i would almost like if i
lived
out that way where he lives where he's
made it
he stalks himself a hundred times but if
i lived out where he lived i would i
would go get a part-time job at that
safeway
just to see just so i could work with
thomas just first one day a week
or at least go shopping just go shopping
there that's true you don't just go
shopping yeah a safe way
all right so this video this is the one
where i was saying maybe we should start
worrying
um so in this video with the title of it
is thomas murph this is the best
okay this might be the greatest video
title
i've ever seen on youtube and you and i
between the two of us
crazy title of a youtube video but this
is this one is so the title is thomas
murphy microwave
hand sanitizer because taylor swift
ruined father's day 2018.
this is the greatest title of a video
ever made
um here we go it's me thomas i'm a
microwave
it's me thomas i'm a microwave hand
sanitizer because i've ruined my
father's day
that can't be saved she ruined my day
mm-hmm tara swift you ruined people's
days
that's right payback's a [ __ ]
here we go
swift [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you um i'll see you at work today
8 30 a.m to 5. so do not buy tara swiss
music she's a horrible singer
and i told star wars 3 stop planner
music i complained to her
so bye bye
okay i have he has over 600 videos mike
i have a couple of questions sure can't
should you microwave hand sanitizer the
answer is no that's a no no i didn't
that wasn't even gonna ask that
is taylor swift terrible yeah probably
how does how did that
get together so wait was taylor swift
the bottle of hand sanitizer am i to
believe that
that the bottle of hand sanitizer was
meant to represent taylor swift and that
he wants to microwave
i i don't know
but i pray that he never runs into her
you also he knew it was going to happen
so he's microwaved handset
you know i thought about that i was
thinking about that excited about what
was gonna happen
sorry one more time she ruined my day
tara swift you ruined people's days and
microwaves
sorry is this
is this at his job somebody asked that
in the chat and i'm not sure well
because look at the
look at the table doesn't the table look
like you know items on it and the table
itself seem very
yeah but he could live in some kind of
shitty apartment she ruined my day
mm-hmm tara swift you ruined people's
days
mm-hmm that's right
payback's a [ __ ] oh i think it's his
apartment because he has a hot plate
over there too
he just has a really apartment where did
he fancy man
[Laughter]
see what i mean he knows it's gonna
happen
tara swift [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
tara swift [ __ ] you that's what you get
um i'll see you at work today 8 30 a.m
to 5.
so do not buy tara swiss music she's a
horrible singer
and i told star wars 3 stop planner
music i complained to her
you're not being reasonable thomas i
don't think you're being reasonable
you know somebody goes destroyed this is
um
[Music]
this isn't this isn't disturbing at all
it's a little troubling right
i knew there was something underneath
that that polite
wound up [ __ ] there's a reason he goes
to those anger classes
i'll tell you that he's a [ __ ] scary
guy